the Joe Rogan experience it was um it
started to slow they come back really
when the X Games came into playing where
suddenly we were we were on TV and kids
could see how much skating had evolved
well the whole public could see how much
skating had evolved from the time that
they last saw it in the late 80s and
then they were seeing and it was like
well these guys are this is for real you
know this is it for lack of a better
word this is a sport these guys are
doing acrobatic things and and it takes
discipline and it takes it takes
determination and and kids recognize
that and I think they you know that's
really when skating started to spark
again and there's like 95 ish probably
more closer to 96 97 the first axioms
was a little strange a little scattered
because it was like skateboarding and
bungee jumping and rock climbing and sky
surfing they're trying to feed they were
just throwing everything and then it
really rubbed us the wrong way because
suddenly we were labeled as extreme and
it was like what do you do i skateboard
oh you're into extreme sports no I'd
skateboard I don't know what yeah that's
a weird category right that extremes it
was just anything yeah and that was I
mean really it was coined by ESPN so
that's why they changed it to X Games so
the first one was extreme games 95 they
changed the X cams in 96 I think they
really found their their niche a few
years later when they really sort of
started to weed out all the random stuff
and it was more about skateboarding BMX
motocross like those became really the
highlights and the reason people are
tuning in and then that's when things
really exploded what were like the early
skateboarding events and X Games like
what did you uh it was it was street and
vert and so vert came back yeah yeah a
lot of it I think it was really because
ESPE recognized that a vert is a
spectator sport yeah I was gonna say for
us on the outside we would watch it to
see someone fall spectacularly yeah sure
guys would go you would hit those ramps
and you would watch people just [ __ ] up
and you're like oh my God look how far
he's falling right yeah for sure and
then once they got in you know once they
evolved that into what they call the big
air ramps the mega ramp then it was just
like the the aerials and the risk factor
was tenfold yeah the the risk factor I
mean I I've seen some wipeouts that are
just I they're baffling I think when
when things started to really explode
with that with the big air thing and
then Jake Brown had his big accident and
one that kind of everyone saw went viral
you probably seen him where he's just
falling from like yeah that's when they
started to I don't want to say tone it
down but but really they started to
figure out how to do it in a way that is
still progressive but not just throwing
caution to the wind and not just trying
to break all the heights and spin
records it was bad - no they really
refined it he I mean
surprisingly he I think he broke his
hand
maybe his his heel and had like internal
bruising but that's it it was I mean it
was really unbelievably lucky yeah I
watched that and I was like this guy
there's no way this guy's gonna live and
this yeah and then didn't you know and
they didn't have the proper protocol in
place they just let him walk off the
ramp it was nuts yeah it was but but it
was definitely a shock to the system and
like I said they started to refine that
event where it's just like alright you
guys you know this is we're comfortable
at this certain height let's just stick
with that yeah even all those skaters
set it themselves they're like well we
can really work on new tricks at this
height instead of trying to go to the
moon go to the moon right yeah
[Applause]